did you know that the Wolf of Wall
Street was funded by one of the biggest
anti-money laundering and Corruption
cases ever behind the world's biggest
financial fraud stands financier Joe low
they called him the Mozart of the
business world he became close with the
family of the Prime Minister of his
native Malaysia and gained unfettered
access to the country's Sovereign wealth
fund investigators discovered that he
siphoned billions of dollars through a
network of shell companies and offshore
accounts worldwide he spent the money on
luxurious real estate and lived a
hustling lifestyle I like to plan my
evenings and make sure that I always go
to the best parties one day Joe learned
that DiCaprio and scorsi wanted to make
a film about the notorious fraudster but
no one was willing to finance it they
were asking for too much but Joe gave
and that's how the Wolf of Wall Street
film came to be in fact the creators
personally thanked Joe in the credits
isn't it an ironic story